bonsoir françois mitterrand est
intervenue ce soir à la télévision à
l'occasion du troisième anniversaire de
son arrivée à l'elysée avant de
développer arrêtons nous sur un autre
phénomène qui lui a volé la vedette
les clips du soleil qui a eu lieu ce
soir elle a fait l'admiration de tous
ceux qui avaient les yeux levés vers le
ciel et à paris ils étaient des milliers
philippe gassot les 200000 parisiens
venus assister à la rencontre céleste
n'ont pas été déçus ils ont attendu
l'événement avec la foi du charbonnier
car personne n'aurait parié un centime
que les gros nuages noirs laisserait
place à une aussi lumineuse rencontre
l'astre de la lumière recevant le baiser
qui laissent des marques sur le col posé
sur la défense avec l'arc pour écrin de
quoi faire des jaloux chez les
bijoutiers de la place vendôme de la
très haute joaillerie le roi soleil
était d'humeur frimeuse pour son clin
d'oeil aux parisiens ils occupaient le
terrain de l'étoile jusqu aux tuileries
ils avaient bien mérité son rayon sa
chaleur car il était resté désert tu
l'as v non pas encore
le papa tu tu avais tu espères j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu tard
maintenant il va falloir attendre 2000
78 ont varié ya un gros nuage c'est
clair on attend ça va peut-être arriver
on verra bien 9 heures et quelques c'est
pas l'heure
c'est vrai que quand c'est pas l'heure
c'est pas l'heure ils ont pourtant
bétonner la position littéralement
occuper les champs elysées sachant que
ceux qui auront la chance de voir la
même chose tout petit aujourd'hui auront
une longue barbe blanche car le rendez
vous est pris dans 84 ans exactement au
mois de mai pour être sur une valait
mieux être là et se presser car vraiment
il y avait le feu